[Music]
look good Jemmy you can test thank you
sir so do you both of you do I thank you
I have to say I like the suit I like the
glasses the the the beard is great the
mustache yes I know this is for your
part mr. Selfridge but then it's got the
little twist at the end which it looks
evil
yes fantastic right uh you know what I
look very hip here's what's happening
I'm old and I need glasses right that's
number one so I have this hipster
situation going on up top right right
and then I've got the hipster mustache
but it's for a role it's for all right
so I'm the only guy that's legit out
there at this at this moment there's
there's nothing hip about me it's just
it's functional yeah say this is
functional like the other guys out there
cuz you see them around they've got a
microbrew that they made themselves
right there in their pajamas they're in
their pajamas they hit they make their
own comic book on the side and they have
the weird twist in the mustache yeah
yours is legit this is legit and it
looks fantastic now let's talk about for
mr. Selfridge the show which we'll talk
about in a minute you've been living in
London yeah you've been living in London
like full-time living in London what is
that like um it's fantastic one day
after work I remember I threw my bags
down I was so excited because my drum
set arrived and this is all I'm gonna
tell sorry I'm not playing the victim
this is my fault okay I take full
responsibility
I didn't know you were a drummer you
were drawn viciously mediocre as a
drummer but I love to play I love to
play so I got home and I threw my bags
down and I immediately launched into
kind of a Keith Moon very aggressive
session and where are we again we're in
my flat in your language London
apartment my apartment indeed and I
looked up and I'm about 36 seconds into
my solo and everyone in my building is
surrounding my drum kit screaming that
I'm killing their children yeah yeah you
get you can't have a drum kit in an
apartment building not what do mean a
parent yeah no that's not apparently not
you just can't do how I can't and and
here's the deal I was so excited I just
didn't know what was happening and I
promised him I would never do it again I
was a sweaty American that lived above
them and I was
for the rest of the time and it's sat
there in my living room like a Ferrari
parked without being able to drive it
right and it was very sad and I I sobbed
like a grandmother every day looking at
it that's the saddest thing I've ever
heard yeah it is a wait a minute no it's
not yeah I've heard plenty of said
things yeah you when you're living there
did you get to meet any cool British
celebrities you know what I went to a
polo match and and and Harry and William
Prince Harry and the the Duke of of you
know what um was there yeah you know you
know we're talking that Duke yes that
old Duke indeed and uh after the polo
match but by the way Harry William
played ridiculously well and they said
you know come and meet the Royals and I
thought okay I'd love to watch other
people meet the Royals but apparently I
was a part of the line and I met both of
them and and Prince Harry kept calling
me Ari and yeah and and yes a he enters
calling her your character name yeah
he's probably sweet it was sweet and I
and I didn't want to be beheaded so I
agreed with him you know I mean I was I
don't haven't had the authority to
behead anyone in about six hundred years
but I I live in fear cause that's what
they want you to think hey I got me man
they could do it